I'm sitting my house Saturday evening
and my mom called me to thank me for the
beautiful flowers I sent her for
Mother's Day having wonderful Mother's
Day you know so we went through our
conversation and then she goes your
father wants to speak to you no that's
always a big deal because my father it's
almost like there's an announcement the
first pitch he's been really nervous my
father oh my god dad
his worst nightmare is that the pitch
would be wildly goes I said you don't
know how unbelievable this is because
this is Gary's worst nightmare literally
talked himself into his worst nightmare
I immediately watched it and Betsy Beth
looks at me and goes I've never seen a
pitch like this so Beth and I go I got a
call Gary I called Gary ago Oh what
happened he goes I'm on my second Scotch
bowl it was unbelievable he was that
devastated that now yet drunk
drunk fortitude like oh that was your
worst nightmare he goes I don't know wha
dude so I didn't want to start busting
his balls to read then I mean for the
Daily News newspaper the most
embarrassing moment in the history of
first pitches Gary Dell'Abate we all
know him as Baba Booey from the Howard
Stern Show delivered what has to be the
most embarrassing ceremonial first pitch
in baseball history had been taking he
had been talking for weeks on the Stern
Show about doing this and Saturday he
finally got his shot here it is do you
know right away that that was the Blake
way okay so how do you realize this is
going hard so I'm standing on the side
and I've got like eight minutes before I
have to go out there I'm just getting
more and more nervous more my nervous I
start to do that thing that I do you
don't have lips no dry heave like when I
get really nervous I start to cough like
a were throw-up oh gee I didn't even
know about that disgust me from the mess
was looking at me like I'm out of my
[ __ ] mind people say just go ahead
and throw it and don't pitch this up
people say go and pitch and what that
was was a bad combination of like of me
saying I'll pitch it at the last minute
go now I'll just throw it you didn't
think it was gonna be this big no I
didn't think was gonna be this bad right
Mary I'm marrying your son's been
relocated yet so we get home on Saturday
and I'm really bummed out Mary's like
God like I've been putting up with this
for two weeks is this gonna go on now
it's all over the [ __ ] news
yeah here's Gary from another angle you
see him pick up his hand high enough
over his head
and now he knows the pictures gone bad
right here there's a beaten man beaten
man so I got a buddy who works for
Rawlings and he knows a little pliers
and he sent me back you know this is
probably the most stinging one of all I
got reports from all the players it's
worse than you imagine oh my god players
are like now it's like I joked at the
clubhouse but here's the question will
this go away eventually or is this one
of those things that's just always gonna
be very very prevalent on the show
always going to be very prevalent on the
show